foreign
let's go to Chicago and talk to Aaron
what's up Hey Ron what's up
hey Dr John how you doing good you doing
well
to win well excellent thanks so much for
uh taking my call appreciate it you got
it man what's happening
Hey so uh just reaching out to you today
just uh for some guidance in regarding a
hard conversation that eventually got to
happen with my mom
um just to give you some background
information for you so
um my father passed away suddenly in
December of 2021. ah man I'm sorry and
yeah no thanks um what was his name
um his name was uh Leon was he pretty
cool
yeah man he was a dust
I miss him every day his name was Leon
did y'all used to watch those Leon
commercials together remember those
oh I don't think so I don't remember
those there ESPN Leon don't
you remember those they were fantastic
oh I don't know tell me something that
was amazing about your dad
um he could just like do so many things
um he was a handy guy he I mean he
helped me like redo my kitchen he
refinished like four or five basements
in his lifetime
um
you see one of those we see one of those
hardcore
um Union or almost Union Chicago guys
that didn't always say the word I love
you but you would wake up at 6am and
they're pulling your cabinets down to
replace them for you
uh no he wasn't a union guy he just uh
he loved to like just stay busy and work
with his hands and just during his
retirement he just was a handy guy and
was painting walls for people and
installing flooring and
um just you know he was uh 75 years old
and he could do like circles around 65
year olds at a time so he sounds like he
uh
he sounds like he
loved well
totally absolutely what a cool I can't I
can think of I hope I hope my kids say
that about me my dad was nuts he was
kind of a but he loved well that's
awesome all right so tell me about your
question hard conversation you gotta
have yeah yeah so um
uh like I said you know just uh it was a
shock to us all and um didn't see it
coming and um so in 2019 my mom and dad
moved to the home where they current
where my mom currently lives and um it's
a bigger home with about you know 26
2800 square feet got three-car garage
decent size you know residential lot
and um you know my mom she's she's
healthy at this point she's she's active
I mean my mom's incredible She's Not
Afraid of hard work she cuts the lawn
she shovels the snow she's uh she's the
active healthy 73 year old as far as I
know and
um just like you know in time just it's
how big the home is and where she lives
just you know my sister and I really
liked her to consider you know just
sizing down just to you know for her own
health and safety and
um just
um also too you know I think it would be
a stress relieve her for her as well
but uh at the same time I think
um
just in previous conversations like
broad conversations she's made the
comment like oh I don't think I could
move again and and things like that and
being that it's been over a year now
that my dad has passed just gotta look
ahead and
have the conversation and just to find
out
um if she'd be willing and just how to
do that
so that that's really like
um my question and your mom I'll tell
you this your mom is lucky to have a
couple of kids who love her so much it's
awesome it's awesome yeah thank you
um all right so I'm going to tell you
some hard truths and then give you maybe
like a plan is that cool sure yeah and
all this I'm just rattling off top of my
head here so it may be worth I don't
want it any other way the free advisor
um it sounds like by the way you just
described this
that this move would be more for you and
your sister and not your mom at this
point
or this move would alleviate your
attention and your fear and your angst
not your mom's
yeah
and I know that sucks to say that out
loud
and you know another thing that's
something that I forgot to mention is um
I mean like I said she's she's healthy I
do know that
um she does kind of have like weaker
bones where she goes in like
monthly temporarily and she's having
like injections done to kind of make her
bones stronger osteoporosis
um yeah she does take like I think
medication for that okay and she has
mentioned to us
um at one point that she was going down
um like uh some steps it was just a two
or three step sets in the house and she
did fall and she didn't like tell us
till two weeks later and he's like Mom
what the heck come on it's when it
happens so does she still have
um
in in inside that home
is there still pictures of your dad
everywhere or his clothes still there
uh no his clothes is not there
um yes there are pictures
um I mean his his tools and things are
are still there
um that's again something that we're
gonna have to like tackle at some point
and figure out
um so here my bigger question is for
your mom
is your dad still inside this home
and um that might be a that's a
different conversation than hey let's
make your life easier
the other conversation is as a family
we've grieved dad for a year and it's
been hard and we've miss him and I can't
even I mean
you still can't even talk about them
without getting choked up because you
loved him so much and he loved you so
much
and
we gotta let that go
and that doesn't mean dad doesn't live
with us in our hearts forever and dad
hasn't made a ripple through time that
will continue to to Ripple through
generations and generations on
right we gotta let that go
and that's a different conversation than
hey Mom what if you didn't have to
shovel the driveway would that sound
awesome see what I'm saying yeah right
so
I would approach so I'm just gonna tell
you this how I would approach this if I
were you okay okay if this was my
situation and my dad just suddenly
passed away my dad's like your dad he
loves recklessly he's a big personality
he's loud and Goofy and uh um just
amazing guy and if he's suddenly just
overnight went away
right so I look up a year later and I
flew to Texas to sit with my mom and
um
what I would say is
mom this house looks like and feels like
so much work
and I want you to hear from me
I want nothing but peace and laughter
and joy for you for the rest of the time
we have you
the moment you're ready to do the hard
work of digging in and selling some of
this stuff and selling the house and
moving to a patio home or moving in our
basement the dad refinished whatever
that looks like I want you to know we
are I'm ready to rock and roll by your
side
and so it's more forming an alliance
unless
pressuring her
more I'm on your team and when you're
ready we will come in with our goggles
on like the home repair shows we'll be
ready to rock and roll
um and less about I'm your son but now
I'm taking the role of your dad I'm
gonna tell you what to do
right
you see you see how that's a little bit
different
totally yeah how does your you know your
mom way better night I mean I don't know
your mom at all how do you how does that
how does that conversation land with her
yeah you know I think um
just you know coming from our heart and
approaching it that way it may
um
turn on a light bulb and make it all
your problem make it a hundred like Mom
I worry about you you're a gangster like
you're out shoveling the snow and doing
flips off the roof into the yard like
you're awesome I am struggling
yeah and maybe that's a a an opportunity
for her to give herself some purpose
well I gotta make my son feel better
again like who knows but make it your
problem at this point now she breaks a
hip
she's unable to move you go by to see
her in the yard is four feet tall and
there's snow everywhere and she can't
get out of the house that's all totally
different conversation
that's the conversation folks have with
their 90 year old dads and they say Dad
I'm taking the car keys you can't drive
anymore you're not safe
right those are hard conversations man
um and you hope that parents will
volunteer right the same as old boxers
dude they have to be told by their
friends and managers and loved ones I'm
not taking your money anymore you got to
stop very few boxers are like all right
all right it's time for me to go that
you don't still do that right right and
so it's hard
um I would make this all on you at this
point you and your sister mom we're
worrying about you we love you we want
you to know that you've got our
permission
to let this house go to let Dad go be
with whatever wherever he is and us to
create a new life with the with the
years we got left
yeah I should
no thought that salad thanks so much
yeah man will you do me a huge favor let
me know how that conversation goes
yeah I will absolutely and one more one
more tiny little piece and I'll let you
go
don't don't spring this honor set it up
okay right no so let her know hey we're
gonna come over we're gonna talk about
future stuff
and it's also a great time to talk about
a will
like does she have a will did your dad
yeah do you know where it is and all
that
I do yeah great awesome awesome awesome
um yeah your parents sound more Amazing
by the second dude that's awesome
when you have those conversations do we
do we know everything is like I just
want to make sure that we're planning
for the future so we can best love you
and take care of you in the coming years
and we're we're we got caught off guard
with Dad it was a shock
we're always we're going to be shocked
no matter what but we want to make sure
we've got all our ducks in a row and
totally
I can't sleep at night because I think
you're going to do somersaults down the
stairs
exactly she's a good 80 year old
snow shoveling Chicago woman she'll
think that's hilarious all right
she sounds awesome hey man um it's been
an honor to talk to you let me know how
that conversation goes um shoot us an
email or give us a call back in and I'll
update the audience here but I want to
hear how that conversation goes my guess
is
she's gonna say thank you for thinking
about us
and not make any decisions for a minute
and then all of a sudden you're gonna
get a call out of the blue that she says
hey it's time let's list the house
and then you're gonna have to go through
your grieving process because it's going
to be very real but that's something
y'all can all do together
life after loss is so hard and y'all are
lucky that you have each other
Stay Together